so if you ask me what are we at the
fundamental physical level I'd say we
are nothing but large collections of
particles atoms electrons protons
neutrons that have configured themselves
into a very specific coherent pattern
that allows us to navigate the world in
the manner that we do there's a
wonderful interplay between the stuff
that we're made of and the ambient
environment and if we had enough time
I'd go through a bit of chemistry a bit
of biology but let me go right to the
level of human mind where we feel who we
are and at that level the language that
you used I would concur with we are
meaning making machines we are pattern
recognition devices we find it very
useful to look out into the world and
organize things